e
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et toujours je vous ai dit me poser vos
questions pour faire une faq de jonas
vegas je pardonne on espère un truc
vraiment cool c'est au golf je pense pas
que vous connaissiez si vous connaissez
des clowns mon commentaire on va aller
se faire sa petite faq là bas ça va être
drôle avec plein d'amis comme ça on
passe une bonne soirée on va se marrer
et en même temps je répondre à vos
questions et n'ont rien c'est tout un
beau gosse
[Musique]
ok
l'histoire en fait ici c'est que vous
connaissez le goal vous preniez vous
jouez vous lancer la balle c'est marrant
sauf qu'ici c'est mieux c'est un toc
goal sagesse de practice dont vous
prenez vous lancer et vous avez terrain
je me range de votre mot explosé vous
avez un terrain qui est énorme c'est pas
d'époque max et pas les fuck maxi
j'explique comment ça marche sauf qu'à
un practice est énorme
derrière vous prenez votre gueule bayrou
balancer sa part là-bas et là vous
marquez des points donc en fonction de
là où vous tirez vous marquez plus ou
moins deux points
en théorie la presse comme ça l'année
dernière max qu'est le champion qui fait
du golf je vois là tu as été très bon et
excellemment beauvais et les battus du
colza parce que tu es très mauvais
excédentaire en revers mais y'en a pris
un retard il un lien donc l'idée c'est
de marquer des points voilà on se marre
c'est comme-ci comme-ça voulait qu'une
petite balle à regarder là
la petite balle elle arrive de l'attak
vous la mettez vous pétez sa part là-bas
ensuite tout réussi sur l'écran on voit
ce qui s'est passé on arrive à suivre
c'est marc henri des points et on se
marre là l'idée un peu top gun bon j'ai
profité je vous montre un petit peu la
partie divertissement fin de ses récents
smaragd épreuve c'est cool et en même
temps je veux répondre à toutes vos
questions
sa collègue pas q je voulais poser avant
de partir j'ai dit que vous et vos
questions justement de concret pour
répondre à la mj carrière ya l'ambiance
n'en ont pas alors on en profite on fait
une petite faq anatole golf et le goal
derrière il ya max qui est là max qui
vas tu participes aussi évidemment bien
évidemment
alors du point fr qu'elle marque de
téléphone moi je peux pas décider que
moi je peux pas je ne peux pas je peux
pas du coup j'ai droit moi ta voix après
apple quoi ouais ok même si c'est vrai
ou alors toi tu dis ok
et pour la troisième guerre mondiale pas
trop croyez-vous que huawei réussir à
s'entendre avec les services google en
fait c'est par wes et la chine c'est la
chine d'acheter us n'est pas du tout bon
et voilà que toi oui bah oui c'est
dommage on est dans son pays ne conduit
pas claude rien est-ce que tu causes
aussi présenté des portables de gaming
n'ont pas laissé sa robe du gaming en
2020 non plus quels téléphones qui
utilisent actuellement fixé à 4 google
existe-t-il un téléphone totalement
français ou totalement non chinois alors
moi je dirais cros kolles heinz koll oui
mais à mon avis est fabriqué en chine
parce que les cuisines sont là bas donc
met en avant mais design et en france
réfléchit en france les produits là où
il ya le savoir-faire donc enchaîner les
passions au paristech et le golf la
santé
abattoir à las vegas points
son plat préféré les blogs les le gluher
guerre à las vegas d'un logiciel de
montage final cut pro et le golf à las
vegas quel est le meilleur monde
connecté rapport qualité prix
[Musique]
ça me détend descoings sur le voir moi
j'ai un fossile à sa gamme génération je
compte vraiment très très bonne une très
grosse autonomie
on peut la garder plusieurs jours avant
que cela va tout changer le décor en
2020 je vais le travailler
pascal boccou cette affaire si tu de rio
à paris qu'elle les meilleurs
smartphones pour les selphy
puis sa fille
moi j'en fais pas et les indiens auront
beaucoup les indiens j'appelle le sel
qui ce temps plein vent
[ __ ] sérieux berry des bains en inde on va
on est bien on va avoir une très bonne
donc et qu'on verrait prochaine fois moi
ce que je pouvais celle qui joue franc
jeu le met à l'envers et j'appuie et ça
marche quand ça bouge et la meilleure
caméra petit hack est ce que la loi copa
va affecter en tant que tueur non parce
que ma chaîne n'est pas dédié aux
enfants
donc pour moi non mais il ya des scènes
pourquoi une partie dans extrêmement
compliqué
les ouvriers et pas moi as tu déjà joué
au jeu vidéo fait le buzz il ya très
longtemps j'ai arrêté parce que ceux ci
prennent beaucoup de temps à jouer au
golf
[Musique]
lagat 3
l'iphone os reporterait et et
l'innovation une amélioration
je suis un peu les îles assez compliqué
c'est vrai des innovations en fait chez
apple s'attend à velonation
mais elles sont là
ça c'est un même toit
pour thomas koch sera enlevée sur les
prochains iphone probablement pas en
2020 j'ai mal gré à gré alors je vais
faire pour toi leur colle sera enlevée
sur les prochains iphone moi je pense
pas en 2020 mais
il va falloir en fait apple il intègre
des technologies une focale sont
éprouvés probablement déjà ailleurs ils
sont moins à gérer avant garde de
l'innovation mais malgré tout ils sont
là quand c'est intégré chez apple ça
marche extrêmement bien à un moment
notre ouïe pour le faire avant toujours
maintenir les caméras de cette vie qui
sont prêtes à intégrer son écran sert
pas qu'à présenter je ne pense pas qu'à
préoccupation la première art qu'elle
présentait en deux mi-temps avec quel
téléphone et lui la meilleure expérience
c'est pas une question de téléphone sa
gestion de l'écosystème m prendra bonne
note et c'est là où des marques comme
samsung comme apple et wau et commence
un peu plus difficile mais notamment
comme apple est extrêmement optimisé
pour l'expérience parce que au-delà la
techno pur d'un produit c'est comme en
lançant fonctionne et ses envies la
tuque un vrai intérêt c'est un appel
tâche et un macbook tâche est une fable
droite ce match est un bon exemple
dubaï à noël
vegas au gulf oil
le golf qu'à sport quel site de vente
achat de tels qu'on les connaît dans
sept jours on parle du reconditionnés
très bientôt donc abonnez-vous s'est pas
déjà le cas yakima que je penses tu que
on aura un jour une alternative android
ios et les pantoufles ce sera bénéfique
aux marchés que la concurrence est
toujours bénéfique aux marchés il faudra
voir dans les temps à venir ce qui peut
se passer du côté de chez huawei ça peut
être intéressant à l'obligation à moment
ou un autre on va se passer un moment je
pense qu'il y avait de la musique
continue faq ailleurs parce que là et
avec la musique on y arrive on va sur le
strip
[Musique]
on va aller dans le tarn
quels axes tombeur hier lise on va au
golden nugget pourquoi elle est le plus
vieux hôtels de vegas qui parlait de moi
du peu
on va éviter la version zombie mais avec
le temps qui courent alors moi j'ai déjà
fait des nuggets essais j'ai bien
longtemps c'est bien contre c'est le
vieux vegas en fait que tu vois dans les
fûts genre assistera de compagnie quand
ça tangue cure
ouais ok
[Musique]
tout le monde
la peau est faux
le corps de garde le plus
mais bon
à tous
[Musique]
ayew sérieux
m
morrison est parti à downtown manhattan
on est ado sano agace on est aux côtés
de la grèce et du cou
on va continuer d'être accueilli dans un
casino à las vegas disputer leur attrait
vieux caisse du casino
date de l'époque de mathusalem
[Musique]
en braquant un téléphone qui fait
réellement car tiers
as tu déjà cassé un téléphone lors d'un
test et
ça m'est déjà arrivé qu'un téléphone qui
casse lors d'un test et pascua du conte
malgré tout ce smartphone je pourrais me
faire quelque chose je peux donc utilisé
pour faire du basket un téléphone
m'attend prouve qu'il ya un problème
d'étanchéité en fin de compte et
l'étanchéité elle a maintenu et c'était
pas bon donc
je t'aime
la marque a un peu la gueule
orange et marron est-ce qu'on peut
presque pas
en prélude à demander quoi mais c'est la
salle parce qu'elle est historique
quand est ce qu'ils testent nos canal +
review je vais demander à nokia j'ai
jamais eu de
réponse donc je pense pas que j'ai fait
malheureusement comme en famille on
arrive à faire des vidéos sur youtube un
peu par hasard en fait j'avais un blog
j'ai fait des conneries jours plus tôt
en vidéo
deux textes apprécions l'appui ça
commence à marcher puis j'ai vécu de
l'attaquant nathan et ça et voilà je
peux déjà te préviens ça fait général et
par hasard
des smartphones ont eu le plus de
plaisir à nous présenter à
celui qui m'a fait plus qu'il fait eux
au niveau de l'âge
la présentation lors de l'événement fox
et de pixels 4 sur les terres du nord et
j'adore dior
ban a dit il dans la récupération de
noël prend les usagers
le traitement de l'eau à brooklyn de
nuit j'étais vraiment génial j'ai kiffé
sa visite aux élus locaux de google et
de youtube directement nous y sommes
donc l'arrêter soutien à jean todt était
cool c'est tout le cadre est tellement
incroyable
quel smartphone tu conseilles de plus
entre le samsung galaxy les iphone c'est
pas une question smartphone c'est une
question de dresser d'écosystèmes j'ai
pas vraiment la question du du produit
parce que si tu prends le haut de gamme
de samsung
et le haut de gamme d'apple fonctionne
merveilleusement bien il ya quelques
petits différentes du point de détail
est pour moi le gros la différence ce
pas vraiment dû
l'eau à 5,29 à trois reprises
quels sont tes tics de langage des
projections amapiens vidéo
boutique de langage
on a passé je les fous propos montage
très serré plein
c'est quoi quitus
en réalité
on aurait vidé y avoir repéré il ya deux
os
quel âge as-tu oh combien coûterait un
smartphone dans quelques années
moi je pense que les smartphones y avait
en arrivant sur le trio gagnant gravity
local je pense à on arrive un petit saut
à skis car il à faire toi 1000 1200 1300
j'imagine pas qu'on va pouvoir mettre
cette fois 1700 1800 sa part tirer
tandis qu'au nord on n'arrive pas très
techno du coup d'éclat vraiment eu de
rapports sont extrêmement bon
j'arrive pas à croire qu'on achètera
aulnoye le smartphone premium destinée à
la vente globale à 1600 rue y en avoir
plus michel enlève ton 512 liga de
stockage mais d'être iphone à 1500 2000
balle grand public je prends 20 passant
par du client la championne
on va dire ça serait pas des clients
[Musique]
bon voilà c'est tout pour aujourd'hui
fin de la faq j'espère que ça vous
seront intéressés ont terminé les
quelque chose comme 2h36 du match j'ai
un avion dont 3,4 points je sais plus
exactement qui sont et qui fait rentrer
se préparer ils sont morts à côté jeunes
et ils m'aiment pas comme pas les
montrer en quoi c'était vraiment cool on
se retrouve très bientôt à vegas 6 6 1
en continu avec de 6es pourra plus elle
vous a raconté d'ici là nous invite à
vous abonner à activer la coche comme ça
vous savez tout et puis voilà si vous
avez d'autres questions on prépare à de
prochaines évacué très très
prochainement j'ai pas pu répondre à
tout le monde je voulais zone est gardé
beaucoup de questions et puis aussi une
grosse soirée ne serait abandonné par
ailleurs ce jour-là ce rendez-vous dès
demain soir tu vas par les textes il
admis
[Musique]
non